ce qui va nous intéresser aujourd'hui
c'est d'essayer de déduire la forme
d'une orbite par exemple si on imagine
un satellite qui tourne autour du soleil
ou autour d'une planète dans le cadre de
la théorie newtonienne de la gravitation
donc ce qu'on se demande en particulier
c'est si on représente une planète au
centre d'un système dax
quelle est la forme de leurs beats suivi
par un petit satellite de masse
négligeable autour de cette planète
on va voir que ces orbites ont des
formes alors là c'est pas très bien
dessinés mais que ces orbites ondées
forme d'ellipse ou de cercles on parle
de conique ou d'orbites de kepler
en particulier pour déduire la forme de
ses orbites on va se placer dans un
repaire encore donné polaire c'est à
dire qu'on va considérer deux variables
la première étant la distance du
satellite par rapport au centre de
l'astre qui l'attirent air et la
deuxième variable étant l'angle par
rapport à un certains axes ont choisi
arbitrairement qu'on appellera t ta
alors pour commencer on va essayer de
rappeler quelques notions pour voir d'où
on peut partir et commencé à écrire des
équations donc une première équation
qu'on peut écrire et qui en fait
l'équation fondamental c'est le fait que
le satellite ne subit qu'une seule force
la force de gravité qui la tire vers
l'astre central qu on notera paix pour
le poids qui est un vecteur dirigé vers
le centre et donc on peut écrire que b
est égale à la force de newton c'est à
dire j'ai mm et la masse de l'astre
mm et la masse du satellite
sur air carrés
avec un moins et le tout dirigé et
suivant la direction er c'est à dire le
rc le vecteur unitaire dirigé dans cette
direction la direction radial donc si ce
qu'on dit c'est que le poids que subit
le satellite c'est une force qui est de
la forme j'ai mm / r carré ça c'est
newton qui nous le dit
jg vert - 1er c'est à dire vers
l'intérieur vers le centre de l'astre
massif
alors à partir d'ici on peut écrire une
deuxième équation c'est l'équation f
égal m à qui nous dit que l'accélération
du satellite à est déduite comme l'afssa
hommes des forces qu'il subit et en
particulier ici la seule force qu'ils
subissent et le poids donc on peut
écrire paix / sa masse donc en
particulier si on utilise l'expression
qu'on a obtenus au dessus
l'accélération du satellite s'est - gm
est ici on divise par petit m sur air
carré fois au vert
alors maintenant ce qu'on va essayer de
faire s'est exprimée l'accélération d'un
point de vue non pas physique ici on
exprime une accélération en fonction des
forces mais d'un point de vue
cinématiques c'est à dire comment
l'accélération le vecteur accélération
est relié aux variations des coordonnées
air et et a donc pour ce faire on va
définir un deuxième vecteur de base
perpendiculaires aux vecteurs er qu'on
appellera cet état qui est le vecteur
dirigé dans la direction selon laquelle
augmente l'angleterre a
donc à partir d'ici on peut écrire que
le vecteur position du satellite le
vecteur r c'est simplement hertz à
distance au centre fois le vecteur er
donc ça c'est assez évident le vecteur r
le vecteur position du satellite c'est
ce vecteur là et on voit que sa longueur
c'est effectivement airs par définition
et sa direction cer également par
définition donc à partir d'ici on peut
obtenir la vitesse du satellite la
vitesse c'est la dérive et du vecteur
position par rapport au temps donc c'est
dr / d'été
qu'on va noter par la suite erp points
donc le point ici voudra dire dérivés
par rapport au temps
et ici on à la dérive et d'un produit
rer donc il faut faire bien attention à
dériver l'un puis l'autre
avec la loi que
uv le tout prime est égale à une prime
vais plus eu des primes à
l'heure à partir d'ici on va vouloir
exprimer la variation du vecteur er par
rapport au temps alors qu'est ce que
c'est que cette dérivé du vecteur er par
rapport au ton bien le vecteur er et
dirigé dans la direction radial donc si
le satellite tourne autour de la str6 à
l'instant suivant elle se trouve ici la
direction radiall a changé et donc le
vecteur er sera dirigée dans une
direction différente et en particulier
le lecteur er aura tourné dans cette
direction là c'est à dire selon le
vecteur est états et leur a tourné
d'autant plus vite que le satellite
s'est déplacée d'un angle grand et donc
ici on peut écrire en fait que er point
donc la dérivée du vecteur er c'est
simplement tête à point la vitesse
angulaire du satellite autour de l'astre
x et état puisque er varie dans la
direction de l etat est en fait de la
même façon peu et a lui aussi a tourné
dans une direction perpendiculaire
et on voit que tu et à tourner vers
l'intérieur puisque il si il était un
peu dirigé vers le haut ici l'est un peu
moins dirigées vers le haut donc il a
dit la tournée dans cette direction là
c'est à dire vers - 1er et donc la
variation au cours du temps de est assez
- teta points 1 er donc ici pour résumer
la vitesse du satellite cr points 1 er
plus ici er point donc c'était à points
1 er donc on aère tête à point em
peut-être
donc maintenant on va pouvoir dérivés ça
une nouvelle fois pour obtenir
l'accélération qui l a dérivé de la
vitesse par rapport au temps
et donc la dérive et de cette expression
ici c'est air point point on dérive ce
premier terme donc compenser la dérive
est secondaire par rapport au temps x e
r + r poi poi fois la dérive et de er
qui était à point des états donc air
pointe et à point peu d'états
plus alors ici on a un produit de 3
terme donc il va falloir dérivés les
trois un par un donc ici on dérive le
premier ça donne r points teta points
peu d'états plus on dérive le deuxième
rt tapant points peu d'états plus on
dérive le troisième terme le troisième
terme c e d'état et on a vu que ça
dérive et c'est moins teta point er donc
ici en réalité on a moins
- r teta poincaré le r et si on regroupe
les termes ici en fonction de r&t tas on
obtient air points points - rt ta
poincaré er donc ces deux termes là
+
2 r pointe et à point ces deux termes se
combinent plus rt tu apprends points peu
d'états
et cette expression ici c'est
l'expression général de l'accélération
d'un corps
encore donné polaire par rapport aux
variations de ses coordonnées air et
état
alors maintenant qu'on a obtenu cette
expression très importante on va pouvoir
égaliser cette expression avec
l'expression qu'on a obtenu juste avant
et en particulier on voit que ce terme
ici doit forcément valoir zéro puisque
l'expression de l'accélération due à la
force de gravité ne dépend que d'eux er
il n'y a aucun terme environ qui dépend
de l'état et comme les deux vecteurs
sont des vecteurs orthogonaux ça
signifie qu ici ce terme doit forcément
être nul
donc on a une égalité qui nous dit que
rta points points ce terme doit être
égale à moins ce terme ici de r pointe
et à pompe
alors ici on va faire une petite
manipulation on peut passer ce terme de
l'autre côté on obtient rt tapant points
donc en additionnant de r pointe et à
point
on obtient plus de r pointe et à points
égal 0 et ici on va pouvoir multiplier
des deux côtés par r on obtient air
carré teta points points +2 r r points
teta points égal 0 donc ça c'est une
astuce qu'il faut connaître ici le fait
de multiplier par air va nous permettre
de remarquer qu'on à la dérive et d'une
certaine grandeur ici on à la dérive et
par rapport au temps de la grandeur r
carré teta points et ceci vaut zéro en
effet quand vous dérivés ça vous avez
d'une part la dérive et de leur caresser
2r donc de r ici par rapport au temps
donc on multiplie par air points soit
état points + r carré fois la dérive et
de tête a pointé à pompe rend donc ici
on sait que la dérive et par rapport au
temps de cette grandeur est forcément
nul ce que ça veut dire c'est que cette
grandeur ici est une constante qui ne va
pas changer au cours du temps cette
constante on va l'appeler h c'est ce
qu'on appelle le moment cinétique
et cette constante donc est une
constante c'est à dire qu'elle ne varie
pas au cours du temps cette grandeur
reste la même quelle que soit la
position du satellite le long de son
orbite alors d'une orbite à une autre
cette grandeur peut varier mais le long
d'une même orbite cette grandeur reste
constante
maintenant d'autre part on peut égaliser
ce terme ici avec ce terme ici donc on
peut écrire une deuxième équation qui
est que air points points - rt ta
poincaré est égal à cette expression -
gm sur air carré est alors ici on va
pouvoir faire utiliser une petite astuce
on voit qu'on a une équation qui est un
peu complexe qui fait intervenir r et
état et en particulier des dérivés de
r&d dérivés de teta donc ce qu'on peut
faire ici c'est utiliser notre constante
h pour déduire la valeur de teta points
en fonction de m ici en dérivant des
deux côtés par air carré on n'obtient
que tu es d'appoint est égal à h / r
carré cette équation va l'encadrer car
il va nous servir
remplaçants is it est à point par h sur
air car et on obtient air points points
- donc ici on a achkhar et sur terre 4 x
est donc sur r3 est égal à - gm sur air
carré et là c'est plus pratique
puisqu'on a une équation qui ne dépend
que d'eux air et de sa dérivée seconde
c'est ce qu'on appelle une équation
différentielle du second ordre et notre
but ici ça va être donc de résoudre
cette équation
alors pour résoudre cette équation on va
utiliser une astuce qui est assez connu
c'est de poser une nouvelle variable
qu'on va appeler eu et qui est
simplement linverse de la distance par
rapport au centre on va voir par la
suite pourquoi cette convention le fait
de poser cette variable va nous aider à
résoudre l'équation donc si on pose une
égale 1 sur air alors eu c'est
évidemment une fonction du temps tout
comme air et donc on peut la dérive et
et on obtient que une pointe à dériver
de hull par rapport au temps c'est
simplement moins un sur air carré ça
c'est la dérive est de 1 sur air fois
air point puisque là on a dérivé par
rapport à air et notre but c'est de
dérivés par rapport au temps donc il
faut multiplier par dr / d'été et si on
dérive une seconde fois une points
points on va obtenir la dérive et de -1
sur air car et donc sa c2 sur hercules
fois air points
mais le tout fois air points à nouveau
puisque on dérive par rapport aux
tendances fois et reprend carré - 1 / r
carré fois est repentant on dérive en ce
deuxième terme
alors ici on peut résoudre cette
équation pour trouver air points points
et en utilisant un peu tout ça en fait
en voyant que upr sont parfaitement
symétrique puisque lui égal 1 sur air et
donc et régale d'un surplus on obtient
également que air poin poin est égal à 2
sur rue au cube fois eut point au carré
- 1 sur rue au carré fois eut point pour
ses textes si on va être très utile
puisqu'on va pouvoir remplacer air
points prend part cette expression
erpent pour un devient donc deux sur
youtube une poincaré moins un sur un
carré us pointent points
- h2 sur r3 alors on a vu que rc1 sûr eu
donc ici on a moins h2 hull 3 est égal à
- gm sur r2 et donc moins gm fois u2
à partir de là on va pouvoir utiliser
une nouvelle astuce qui va nous
permettre de résoudre l'équation on voit
ici qu'on a une équation assez complexe
avec une dérivée seconde est une dérive
et première au carré et pour simplifier
tout ça on va ne plus ce qu'on ne plus
se concentrer sur l'équation de nu par
rapport au temps mais l'équation de l'ue
par rapport à l'anglais état puisque ce
qui nous intéresse c'est de connaître la
forme de leurs beats donc la vitesse à
laquelle l'orbité parcouru ne nous
intéresse pas tant ce qui nous intéresse
c'est vraiment de connaître pour chaque
anglet et à la distance au centre de
leurs beats pour pouvoir tracer la forme
de leur [ __ ]
donc pour faire ça il va falloir
exprimer une points et urbain points en
fonction des dérivés de hull par rapport
à tes tu as donc on va noter une prime à
la dérive et 2u par rapport à l'état et
aux primes prime la dérivée seconde de u
par rapport à l'état
et donc à partir de là on peut noter que
eut point c'est la dérive et 2u par
rapport à tes
qui est donc en décomposant la dérive et
de huer par rapport à l'état 2 x la
dérive et de teta par rapport au temps
en fait c'est la dérive et d'une
fonction composé ici donc on va changer
de vision considère que lui et
maintenant une fonction de teta qui est
lui même une fonction de tes donc la
dérive et tout ça c'est la dérive et de
hull par rapport à l'état donc c'est une
prime était ta foi tête à prime 2 t et
donc c'est la formule qu'on a ici bon et
bien d etat sur des t on le connaît il
nous est donné par cette expression ch
sur r2 c'est-à-dire h fois u2 et donc on
a une prime d u sur des états
x h u2
maintenant on peut dériver une deuxième
fois pour obtenir une points points et
un point point est égale donc à la
dérive et de tout ça par rapport au
temps donc la dérive et 2h u2 par
rapport au temps
c'est 2 h une fois eu point
plus
ici on veut la dérive et par rapport au
temps de une prime d u prime sur d'été
x h u2 et ça on va pouvoir le décomposer
alors déjà eu point ici on sait que
c'est cette expression ici donc on peut
le remplacer par cette expression donc
on a 2 h carey
est ici devient eu trois
fois une prime car est
donc cette expression là c'est ça
plus
h u 2
x alors d u prime sur d'été cdi prime
sur des états
x dette et assure d'été
et ça c'était à point on a vu que
c'était h u2 est donc ici on peut
remplacer était à point par hq2 ce qui
nous donne h carré et eu quatre
ici d u prime sur des états c'est une
prime prime la dérivée seconde de hull
par rapport à l'angle d'état et si on a
bien obtenu l'expression de hull
points.la dérivée seconde de vue par
rapport au temps en fonction des dérivés
de hull par rapport à l'anglais état
et à partir d'ici on va pouvoir
remplacer donc ces deux expressions
alors on a aussi cette expression là
avec une prime
et donc ces deux équations ici vont nous
permettre d'exprimer toute cette
équation par rapport à tes tu as donc on
commence on a deux sur youtube fois eu
poincaré eut point c'est tout ça donc du
point carré ch carey eu 4 u prime carré
- 1 / uqar et fois upu point point du
pont quand c'est tout ça donc on a deux
achkar et u13 une prime de plus achkar
ait eu 4 u primes prime tout ça - h 2 ou
3 est égal à - gm u2 donc toute cette
équation ici c'est l'équation qui est
au-dessus réécrite par rapport non plus
aux dérives et temporelle mais aux
dérivés angulaire de la fonction eu
loris si on peut un peu simplifié on
voit que ici le u3
se simplifient avec le but 4 pour donner
eu ici le 1 sur u2
va venir donner alors ici on a au moins
un sur u2 va venir donner une
et u2
maintenant on voit qu'on a beaucoup de
hache carré alors je vais écrire le de
ici pour que soient plus visibles
on voit qu'on a beaucoup de achkhar et
donc on peut diviser par achkhar et
donc ici ça nous divise le terme de
droite par h carré et on remarque ces
deux termes s'annulent parfaitement et
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait cette
manipulation en fait c'est une heure
c'est ce qui va simplifier tout la
résolution de l'équation
et pour finir on peut diviser par l'uqar
et
on obtient une équation qui est assez
simple alors je vais la réécrire en
multipliant tout parent - 1 pour obtenir
des plus on obtient une prime prime un
plus lui est égal à gm sur achkhar et
cette équation c'est vraiment l'équation
finale qui va nous permettre de trouver
la forme des ellipses dans le modèle de
la gravitation de newton
pour ceux qui sont intéressés dans le
modèle de la gravitation
relativiste dans la relativité générale
on a un terme qui vient s'ajouter ici
qui est en lui carey et dont la dans la
taille est très petit il dépend du rayon
de schwarzschild c'est à dire qu'il est
très petit par rapport à la vitesse de
la lumière
[Musique]
bon eh bien maintenant il nous reste
seulement à résoudre cette équation
alors on a une équation ici qui n'est
pas homogène c'est à dire qu'on a une
constante du côté droit alors pour
résoudre cette équation va commencer par
résoudre l'équation homogène donc
comment résoudre déjà si on n'avait pas
de constance comment résoudre une prime
prime plus égale zéro bien ça en
réarrangeant ça nous donne une prime
prime égale moins eu et on reconnaît
l'équation d'un oscillateur harmonique
dont la fréquence est de 1 donc la
solution de cette équation c'est u égal
une certaine constante à
fois le cosinus du l'angle d'état ici
puisque la variable par rapport à
laquelle on dérive cet état donc de
l'anglais et à plus ou moins une
certaine constante et à 0 qui vient du
fait qu'on a un second degré de liberté
puisqu'ici on a une équation du second
degré et ça c'est la solution donc pour
l'équation homogène alors maintenant
pour résoudre l'équation ici qui n'est
pas homogène l'équation complète il
suffit d'ajouter une constante b et de
remettre ça réinjecter ça dans
l'équation pour trouver la constance b
donc ici si on dérive on a une prime qui
est égale à la dérive et de ça c'est à
dire donc le b s'en va on a moins à
sinus teta - tête à zéro c'est la dérive
et du caussinus qui donne moins sinus
et donc une prime prime la dérivée
seconde c'est à nouveau la dérive et de
souci on obtient moins à caussinus la
dérivée du sinus et caussinus de teta -
tête à 0 et donc une prime crimes plus
eu
c'est moins à caussinus plus à caussinus
plus b et donc cb donc la constante b
ici c'est simplement cette constante la
gm
sur h carré et là on a obtenu la formule
finale
la solution j'ai la plus générale de
notre équation
est alors si on se souvient que eu
c'était un super eh bien on peut
simplement inversé ceux ci aient trouvé
que air en fonction de l'état est donné
par l' inverse de saint lary si on va
simplement factoriser par gm sur achkhar
et donc ici si je factories j'obtiens
plus un ici la constante qui change mais
ça reste une constante arbitraire donc
on va on peut simplement la renommée
atild pour indiquer que c'est pas la
même constante ici est donc en inversant
ceci on obtient achkhar et sur gm au
numérateur et le dénominateur un plus
une constante qu'on va renommer e
fois le cosinus de teta - et à 0
ceci c'est l'équation finale de la vidéo
c'est ce qu'on cherchait on a obtenu la
forme d'une orbite encore donné radial
encore donné polaire
en fonction de deux constantes h qui est
le moment cinétique de l'orbité et eux
qu'on appelle l'excentricité de leurs
beats alors que représente
l'excentricité c'est à dire qu'on peut
avoir des orbites de la forme circulaire
alors c'est pas très bien dessinés mais
il faut imaginer un cercle donc ça c'est
quand eux égal zéro on voit que caen est
égal zéro est régal une constante et
donc si air égale une constante on à
l'équation d'un cercle et plus eux
augmentent plus lors beat devient
excentré c'est à dire que son centre se
décale par rapport à l'astre massif et
l'orbiel devient elliptique on a une
orbite en forme d'ellipse c'est-à-dire
un cercle allongée lorsque vos seins
lors bit se découpe en deux on a une
parabole c'est à partir de ce moment que
le satellite peut s'échapper les le
satellite a suffisamment d'énergie pour
s'échapper de l'attraction
gravitationnelle
et quant à eux est plus grand que ça on
obtient des hyperboles ce sont des
trajectoires avec encore plus d'énergie
la constante est à zéro quant à elle
correspond simplement à laax
d'orientation de l'orbité donc si on
imagine qu'on a une ellipse comme ça
pour tes à 0 égal zéro donc aligné avec
l' axe horizontal si on augmente
l'angleterre à 0 et bien lors beat va se
décaler comme ça et donc tu est à zéro
c'est vraiment seulement l'orientation
de la rrq ce qu'on choisit donc c'est
une constante qui est purement
arbitraire et qui n'a rien de physique